hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well Emanuel Kant begins his conclusion
at the end of part three of the proma to
any future metaphysics by talking about
several
absurdities unight is the term that he
uses for absurdity there quite literally
things that don't rhyme things that
don't Jive together and then it comes by
extension to mean something that's
nonsensical or absurd and it's none of
these are
nonsensical in that we can't make any
sense of them at all but they're all
kind of mistakes they become absurdities
when we think them through so he begins
by saying that the clearest arguments
having been induced in the previous
sections it would be absurd it would be
an absurdity for us to hope that we can
know more of any object than belongs to
the possible experience of it so why
can't we know more of any object than
what belongs to possible experience of
it well we encounter possible objects
within possible or actual experience
that is what it is to be an object it is
something that we conceive of as being
in space and
time then he goes on and he says or lay
claim to the least knowledge of how
anything not assumed to be an object of
possible experience is
determined by the
Constitution that it has in itself so we
can't actually penetrate to the things
in themselves they lie outside of
experience by the very nature of what
they are and so we can't apply the
categories and Concepts that we use for
experiential matters to them or we can
if we want to wind up in absurdity right
and then a bit later he's going to talk
about other greater absurdities he says
it would be on the other hand still
greater if we conceeded know things in
themselves so even though we can't know
anything about the constitution of
things in themselves even though we
can't know more of any object than what
is contained in possible experience
nevertheless we're stuck saying that
there are things in themselves what
exactly these are we don't know right
but we can't just throw them away or
rule them out either and he goes on and
says a few other things here if we were
to declare and then there's three things
that he notes our experience to be the
only possible mode of knowing things so
we can't restrict knowledge or cognition
to only experience or our intuition of
them in space and time to be the only
possible intuition other modes of
intuition are perhaps possible maybe
even to some degree imaginable if not
conceivable and now notice in the last
one our discursive understanding to be
the archetype of
every possible understanding Kant is
holding out the possibility that maybe
our seemingly completely Universal
understanding is not such right and then
he goes on and says and to have the
principles of the possibility of
experience taken for Universal
conditions of things in themselves and
this is something he's talked about
before we have uh great knowledge now at
this point at least in in the Universal
or general about the conditions of
experience things in themselves we
cannot apply that knowledge that we have
to the things in themselves and say aha
we've got this and this is what
dogmatism actually does which leads then
to skepticism right so we we have and
we've seen this before in the proma
these sort of three isms uh or we have
three positions you could
say dogmatism which is committing it
self committing the person who's making
the claims to more than they actually do
know skepticism which arises as a
counter to dogmatism both in kant's own
view sort of ahistorically and also
historically as well and then we have
transcendental critique that which Kant
is providing in his own philosophy which
is going Beyond dogmatism and skep
skepticism both but skepticism is an
important moment in this and Kant tells
us that what does skepticism arise from
metaphysics and the Lawless dialectic of
pure reason and that's kind of a cool
way to talk about it and it's also kind
of revealing right the dialectic as
we've seen in the discussion of the
ideas the psychological the cosmological
and the theological there is kind of you
know regularity or understandability to
it right an
intelligibility but it can be Lawless in
that it is not going to be limited or
confined by reason itself as it should
be so what forms do this skepticism take
he says that um well our principles
which limit the use of reason to
possible experience might might become
Transcendent on the limits of our reason
be set up as limits of the possibility
of things in themselves he brings up
hume's dialogues on natural religion as
an illustration of this and then he says
if a careful critique did not guard the
bounds of our reason we'll come back to
that so he says skepticism arises right
at first it might merely to favor the
empirical use of reason rationality is
used with empirical experiential matters
right and anounce that everything that
transcends this use as worthless
valueless and deceitful leading us
astray so you know this is something
that we could find In classical
skepticism of various sorts we can also
find this in David Hume he says H you
can reason about anything you like once
you get beyond the realm of experience
you're on really really shaky ground
because you can imagine anything you
like that way so that's that's one way
of going and then he says well it can go
even further it can lead to doubting
even the
propositions of experience
right that would be a real problem maybe
we need to like re in dogmatic reasoning
about things that's a prudent sort of
skepticism but we could also call into
doubt as for example di Hart did uh and
so many others as well the things that
we do experience because how do we know
that we can trust any of those that's a
big problem and K here is actually going
to talk about a confusion a fing he's
going to use that term twice in science
visen shaft itself about reason right he
says the confusion
is that science cannot determine how far
reason is to be trusted and why only so
far and no further right so science
which is a use of reason is not able to
set
limits reasonable limits if we want to
be a little punny limits that have their
own basis in rationality itself on
reason it can't provide an
intelligibility
to where reason can go and whether it
can be trusted and why in this respect
it can be and in this respect it can't
be and we should pause for a moment on
this word science right so visena
science is a broader term than what in
English we often confine merely to the
Natural Sciences along with
mathematics and then uh the the social
sciences and perhaps some other things
as well we talk about computer science
for example uh which is really concerned
with technology and and codes and
hardware and things like that um
metaphysics itself is striving to be a
science so K here is using science in a
broader sense and this would actually
lead to science in the very broad sense
being able to in you know rework what's
previously been dogmatic metaphysics
into something that could be satisfying
and so he says the only way we can clear
up this confusion and prevent future
relapses is through uh critique through
the critical use of our reason
right so he says uh what what does this
lead us to well we can't as he says um
beyond all possible experience form a
definition
notion now that should actually be
concept that's the term that he's using
there of what things in themselves may
be but we are not as he says at Liberty
to abstain entirely from inquiring into
them so we're kind of stuck in the
middle we cannot actually form
Concepts definite Concepts we can form
an indefinite concept of a thing in
itself or things in themselves but we
can't resist them we can't completely
turn away from them at least not if our
reason is working you could say and he
says why is that the case experience
never fully satisfies reason it couldn't
the realm of experience is too narrow to
fully satisfy this faculty of reason and
he says in answering questions it refers
us further and further back and leaves
us dissatisfied with regard to their
complete solution and so you know he
says we can gather this from the
dialectic of pure reason which has good
subjective grounds and now he's going to
give us three examples of how this works
familiar to anybody who's read the
earlier section first we have the
psychological idea says who can refrain
from asking what the soul really is and
if no concept of experience suffices for
that purpose from accounting for for it
by a concept of Reason a simple
immaterial being a substance you can say
right even though we cannot by any means
prove its objective reality so we're
inevitably attracted into thinking about
the soul or if you like the self
whatever you want to call that
substantial Unity of Consciousness then
we have a whole bunch of ideas as we saw
before the
cosmological ideas which are actually
antinomies and they are framed in terms
of questions he says who can satisfy
himself with mere empirical knowledge in
all the cosmological questions of the
duration time light right or beginning
or not and the magnitude of the world
Freedom or natural necessity that's the
third one uh since every answer given on
principles of experience begets a fra
question now this is very interesting
answering things sometimes doesn't
answer them because it leaves new
questions open or it brings them to the
for for us and he says each of these
likewise requires its answer and shows
the insufficiency of all physical modes
of explanation to satisfy reason and
then he comes to the third what we call
the theological idea or the ideal of
pure reason
he says who does not see in the
thoroughgoing contingency and dependence
of all his thoughts and assumptions on
mere principles of experience the
impossibility of stopping there who does
not feel himself compelled
notwithstanding all interdictions
against losing himself in Transcendent
ideas to seek rest and contentment
beyond all the concepts which he can
vindicate by experience in the concept
of a being the possibility of which
cannot be conceived
but at the same time cannot be refuted
because it relates to a mere being of
the understanding and without it reason
must needs remain forever dissatisfied
so all these ideas that that form part
of the dialectic of pure reason
inevitably arise for us and the goal
here then is to look at them in a
critical Manner and part of that is not
trying to actually resolve them and
explain them away by saying ah they
don't refer to anything there's nothing
there no there's there's something that
we're being drawn to we just cannot buy
the tools that we have available from
the understanding from our intuitions
through space and time through possible
experience we cannot account for them in
that way and we cannot determine those
ideas in the ways that we can determine
other concepts by use of the
understanding reason is thereby drawn
away from dogmatism away from skepticism
into its critical and also
transcendental usage so that we can
develop metaphysics into an actual
science